the country experienced in the second quarter a
growth of 0 2% and we expect
this trend to continue we have
come out of the period very great
difficulties greek sites threatened
but you also see that the work on
the reforms must continue to move forward
to install  comparable to demonstrations as
a positive force tabarly jaswinder singh does
nothing
kroloff jean marc ayrault my friends
is young beautiful funny in greek water mac site
three municipalities and smooth but only
one passive one pressure from
representatives of other
european peoples who have the euro for  currency
will help our Greek friends to
carry out the reforms and to provide the
necessary education to their
public opinion the Greek debt is
unsustainable
it is close to 100 80% of the pipe
despite three successive financial support plans
it is  the reason why
including the imf last september 23
pleaded in favor of debt relief
stein pia qui rit mos  covici will need is
love from nat team the citizen who has
nothing but here sap domain and
draka taxis which touches the
exceptional snow to go